July 1942 the United States is fighting
tooth and nail to beat the Nazis it's a
nationwide effort to defeat the greatest
evil the world has ever known so the
head of a secret government agency
directs Harvard to create a research lab
to build advanced anti-radar technology
this lab was so secret that I can't show
you a photo of it because no photos of
it even exist it was called the radio
research lab It ultimately helped the
Allies win the war but that wasn't even
its biggest Legacy because the lab
marked the beginning of Silicon Valley
as we know it today Apple Google
Microsoft Amazon these companies owe
their entire existence to an incredible
series of events that unfolded during
World War II don't believe me well let's
Dive In
Adolf Hitler wanted to take Britain out
of the war but he knew that a land
Invasion against a heavily defended
Island would fail so he turned to his
commander of the German air force and
decided to bomb British industrial
targets for months German bombs fell on
British cities in a campaign known as
The Blitz
starting on September 7th 1940 London
was bombed by the luftwaffe for 56 of
the following 57 days and nights it was
terrifying but thanks to a combination
of British resilience and Ingenuity the
blitz failed and this opened the door
for a counter-attack Allied air
commanders knew the Germans had over
committed but they were still cut off
from the massive land battles raging on
the European Mainland so they launched a
major strategic bombing campaign of
their own and their aim wasn't to sow
Terror instead they wanted to [__]
the Nazi's ability to wage war actually
executing this plan however required
taking back control of the Skies
thousands of Fighters and bombers took
off from British and American airfields
piloted by men barely older than boys
they were flying straight into the belly
of the Beast even by the standards of
World War II aerial missions were
insanely dangerous over the course of
the war half of all Allied air Crews
were killed while on operations of the
many threats Allied Pilots faced one of
the most formidable was the German air
defense network the Germans brought it
online in 1941. British Pilots named it
the kamu bear line for the colonel who
devised it the first version of the line
consisted of several overlapping radar
stations covering a Zone about 20 miles
long and 12 miles wide
these stations were linked by a Hamilton
Zone if you speak German you'll know
that himmelbet means canopy bed only
these were much less inviting each Himel
bet Zone consisted of a Freya radar with
a range of more than 60 miles these
Radars controlled a master Searchlight a
himo bet was also assigned one primary
and one backup fighter plane RAF pilots
flying into Germany had to cross the
camhu bear line when they did the Freya
radar operators used the master
Searchlight to spot them and then sent
night fighters to shoot them down these
night Fighters were some of the best
planes the luftwaffe had and they were
flown by some of Germany's top Pilots as
if that wasn't enough the Germans soon
developed a more accurate tracking radar
called the warsberg which they added to
each Himel bet Zone one wurzberg would
lock onto the German Interceptor while
the second would lock onto the Allied
plane as soon as the Freya picked it up
each wordersburg radar had a 45 mile
range and was fully mobile when the
Germans suspected more bombers were
incoming or that their Radars could come
under attack they would simply put them
on a truck and move them somewhere else
initially the cam who bear line was
devastatingly effective British
commanders just didn't have an effective
counter their pilots were Guided by
their instincts not by tactics they flew
their own paths towards German airspace
and were easily picked off something had
to change
enter a man named Reginald Victor Jones
Jones was a British physicist and
Military Intelligence expert he also
loved practical jokes once when he was a
student in the 1920s Jones called a
classmate and convinced him to drop his
phone into a bucket of water to clean
out the bugs a few years later Jones
convinced a reporter that he had
invented a device which when attached to
a phone allowed him to see everything
the reporter was doing the reporter was
skeptical until Jones described how he
was dressed with perfect accuracy how
did he know because he was peering down
at the reporter from the next building
his love of tricks and deception
filtered through to his work during the
blitz he was one of the first people to
realize that the Germans were using
radio beams to guide their bombing runs
when faced with the problem of how to
safely cross the camhu bear line Jones
told British Air Force commanders to
reorganize their attacks into streams
and fly in a tight cluster down the
middle of a himobat Zone the the new
tactic made its debut on the night of
May 30th 1942 when 1100 RAF bombers
attacked the German city of Cologne
codenamed operation Millennium it was
the biggest bombing raid of the war so
far British commanders hoped that the
raid would be so devastating that it
might even knock Germany out of the war
that didn't happen though and in truth
the results were slightly underwhelming
cologne was still standing but operation
Millennium proved that Reginald Jones
was right less than four percent of the
bombers sent on that raid were shot down
the German air defenses which had struck
fear into British Hearts were
overwhelmed but the Germans weren't
about to give up so easily they
immediately started making important
adjustments luftwaffe commanders began
directing all available Fighters within
range to intercept the British bomber
stream and the German war machine got to
work producing hundreds of additional
wartersburg Radars at the height of the
war more than 5 000 were deployed in a
line stretching from Denmark to the
middle of France further technical
improvements meant that the bet zones
expanded until they reached 100 miles
across Germany's biggest cities and
industrial areas were soon shielded by
concentric layers the kamu bear line
once again became highly effective at
deterring Allied bombing raids the
bomber stream worked until the Germans
responded
the next major Innovation came when the
British and then the Americans developed
air-to-ground pathfinding radar to help
their bombers see through the clouds the
Germans realized that this effectively
turned the Allied bombers into big
beacons in the sky so in response they
invented a mobile radar receiver
codenamed naxos that picked up their
locations this was really just the
world's most dangerous cat and mouse
game at this point the Allies would
devise a solution to increase the
efficiency of their bombing raids the
Germans would respond the Allies would
respond back and on and on it went
control of the Skies was the difference
between the German war machine being
stopped in its tracks or rolling across
Europe Allied air commanders knew the
German air defense systems were
devastating their bombers but they
didn't even know what Radars the Germans
were using or how they were controlling
their night fighters in order to defeat
the cam Huber line the Allies needed to
understand it and they needed to do it
fast but the same old incremental
improvements wouldn't cut it they needed
a complete paradigm shift a
technological innovation so so big that
the Germans simply couldn't keep up
finding it would require transforming
the relationship between scientists and
the military
many people believe that if the Japanese
hadn't attacked Pearl Harbor then the
United States would have never entered
the war while it's true that the attack
shocked the world America's leaders had
already been preparing for years it was
just impossible to miss the ominous
storm clouds that were gathering during
the 1930s in Germany Hitler Rose to
Power by exploiting resentments about
the aftermath of World War One in Spain
a group of fascist Military Officers
staged a coup which led to a brutal
Civil War meanwhile in Asia the Japanese
had invaded China and were occupying
Manchuria tensions were Rising across
the world every part of society had to
respond in the United States the
scientific Community was led at that
time by a man named vanavar Bush and
Bush is an absolute Giant in the history
of American Science originally an
engineer who received his PhD jointly
from MIT and Harvard his inventions in
the field of analog Computing led to him
being promoted to senior positions in
science Administration when the Nazis
invaded Poland on September first of
1939 Bush held the prestigious position
of president of the Carnegie Institute
of science he could see that the U.S
desperately needed closer cooperation
between its civilian scientists and the
military all across the country
thousands of talented men and women were
working on technologies that could
change the outcome of the war but they
weren't encouraged to share or
commercialize their results Bush wanted
them to be closer to the action on June
12 1940 he secured a meeting with
President Roosevelt Bush brought a
single piece of paper describing his
idea a new agency that would oversee
research on the problems underlying the
development production and use of
mechanisms and devices of warfare it
must have been a good presentation
because FDR approved it in 10 minutes
two weeks later the National Defense
research committee or ndrc was born by
enlisting some of America's best
scientists and Engineers directly in the
war effort Bush knew he was going
against the grain the ndrc focused on
accelerating the development of two key
military Technologies the first was the
atomic bomb the second was radar the
potential of radar to identify and track
military targets was widely understood
and important work was already going on
all over the world two American Brothers
deeply alarmed by acts of unprovoked
German aggression collaborated with
Stanford to create a device which
eventually proved to be the key to
microwave-based radio detection and just
a few months before President Roosevelt
created the ndrc with a stroke of his
pen researchers at Birmingham University
invented a device called the cavity
magnetron the magnetron was a huge step
forward because it made high frequency
microwaves viable microwaves had long
been considered one of the most
promising radar Technologies they could
carry more information using less power
but there wasn't a reliable way to
actually generate them the magnetron
solved that problem shortly after this
breakthrough President Roosevelt and
prime minister Churchill agreed that
their country should share their top
secret research British scientists
showed the magnetron to their impressed
American counterparts military leaders
wanted to make them at home and
scientists wanted to work on further
improvements the Americans and Brits
agreed to establish a new jointly
administered research facility it opened
at MIT in October of 1940. it was called
the radiation laboratory the rad lab for
short the name was deliberately
deceptive it was chosen to make people
think that the lab focused on nuclear
physics research at a time when almost
no one believed Nuclear Physics had
viable military applications so money
from the ndrc the rad lab grew rapidly
at its peak the lab employed more than 4
000 people it was the perfect example of
what the physicist Ernest Lawrence
called big science
the idea behind big science was simple
but revolutionary Fields like physics
and electronics had Advanced to the
point where most cutting-edge work was
too complex for small academic Labs the
era of individual physicists doing an
experiment at their desk was over in its
place you needed big multi-disciplinary
research teams working in Labs full of
sophisticated equipment running those
labs required scientists engineers
managers accounts and support staff like
secretaries and janitors simply put big
science wasn't cheap in fact it was too
expensive for the private sector which
left just one source of funding the
government and it was a natural fit
proponents of big science saw it as the
perfect marriage of America's scientific
prowess and prodigious industrial
manufacturing capabilities they
convinced the government that science
could solve the country's biggest
problems in June of 1941 the U.S
government established the office of
scientific research and development
vanivar Bush was appointed its inaugural
director before World War II and before
vanavar Bush military r d was performed
exclusively in military Labs his
fundamental Insight was to enlist
America's universities and scientists in
the war effort his office funded
universities directly we're talking tens
or even hundreds of millions of dollars
huge money for the 1940s men of our
Bush's time at the office of scientific
research and development transformed the
relationship between academic science
and the U.S government and it was about
to change the life of a man named Fred
Turman I was always interested in
science and electrical engineering
electrical things way back when I was 10
11 12 years old Turman completed his
undergrad and Masters at Stanford in the
1920s after graduating Turman went back
to California to join Stanford's
engineering faculty and he didn't waste
any time he designed a course created a
new lab focusing on Research into vacuum
tubes and even wrote one of the most
important textbooks on electrical and
radio engineering Turman could have
carved out a great career in relative
obscurity but then the world changed and
all of a sudden his skills were critical
to the Allied war effort one day in
early 1942 the phone rang
it was turman's old thesis advisor
vanavar bush bush explained that his
agency was about to open a new lab to
conduct top secret research on
electronic countermeasures an emerging
field of technologies that blocked enemy
Radars and Communications Bush believed
that electronic countermeasures could
provide the allies with the decisive
Advantage they needed to win the
European air War once and for all and he
wanted Fred Turman to run the lab
working on it Turman didn't have deep
expertise in electronic countermeasures
the field was so new that no one did
it's fascinating to think about what was
running through turman's head at that
time he must have had doubts but he
understood that he was being asked to do
something important for his country so
he moved back to Massachusetts to run
the Harvard radio research lab help the
Allies win World War II and although he
didn't know it at the time take a huge
step toward the creation of Silicon
Valley
Fred Turman was the general of a very
new kind of army the 850 men and women
he led at the radio research lab weren't
soldiers they fought their battles in
the lab not in the trenches but make no
mistake they were fighting Turman and
his staff had one mission to
systematically dismantle every part of
the German air defense system over the
course of the war they created more than
150 anti-radar devices the radio
research lab was the dark twin of what
was happening across town at the rad lab
sometimes the MIT scientists would
notice their radar equipment wasn't
working what they didn't realize was
that their colleagues at the Harvard
radio research lab were turning on their
Jammers and screwing with them Reginald
Jones the fun-loving British scientist
who came up with the idea of the bomber
stream would have been proud
now radar countermeasures have two main
uses the first is basically blinding the
enemy's radar or tricking it into
reporting wrong information the second
is to get the enemy's radar to
unintentionally reveal its location
effectively turning the Master's
creation against him whatever the nature
of the specific task the first step in
countering enemy radar is locating where
it's coming from and its wavelengths and
frequencies during the air War over
Europe This reconnaissance was done by
small ferret planes so called because
they used search receivers to ferret out
enemy radar signals crucially anti-radar
detectors had a big advantage over radar
itself radar was limited to the distance
at which it could pick up the echo of
its own signal anti-radar devices didn't
need to broadcast they could just listen
in near silence once the enemy's radar
was located it had to be jammed two main
radar jamming techniques were developed
in the field and perfected at the radio
research lab the first method involved
aluminum foil the scientists had
discovered that if you cut a strip of
any metallic object to half the
wavelength of a radar signal the signal
would bounce back confusing the radar
and the person operating it foil was
chosen because it was cheap and light so
it floated in the sky the Allies called
it window we know it today as chaff
suddenly planes escorting Allied bombers
started dumping thousands of chaff
packets out of their holes with each
packet containing thousands of
individual strips this tactic was first
used in operation Gamora a bombing run
of Hamburg in July of 1943. clouds of
aluminum foil strips dropped by
Pathfinder planes and the initial bomber
stream completely clouded the German
radar defenses the result was the city's
total Destruction as many as 40 000
people perished one-third of hamburg's
large factories and almost half of its
small factories were destroyed it's
believed that Hitler himself was alarmed
that several more bombing raids like the
one inflicted on Hamburg could push
Germany out of the war the second method
uses electronic Jammers high frequency
transmitters which overwhelmed enemy
radar installations with radio waves
broadcast at the same frequency they
became known as carpet Jammers thanks
mainly to the work of Fred Turman and
his team 24
000 carpet Jammers were installed on
Allied bombers there were entire
factories in the US making only carpet
Jammers the mighty German Radars that
had been a thorn in the side of Allied
bombers for years the Freya the mammoth
the warsberg simply couldn't handle it
German anti-aircraft efficiency was
reduced by 75 percent the radio research
lab team led by Fred Turman even
developed a powerful ground-based Jammer
to use against enemy Airborne radar the
Germans managed to devise some partly
effective counter-jamming measures but
they were never able to fully answer the
questions that the Allies had started
asking by the end of the war 90 of
Germany's high frequency radio experts
about 7 000 men were diverted from other
urgent work to try and prevent the
jamming of German radar the battle for
supremacy of European Skies was over and
soon so was the war Fred Turman built
the Harvard radio research lab from
nothing into the world leader in every
type of advanced microwave device the
work done by his lab was credited with
preventing the loss of 450 bombers and
more than 4 500 lives in the United
States main bomber Squadron The Eighth
Air Force but with the war over it had
fulfilled its role it was disbanded in
1946 as silently as it started and Fred
Turman was faced with a question what
now
he decided to return to the place he
knew best Stanford Herman already had
tenure there and after his work running
the radio research lab he had three more
things an address book full of
high-powered military contacts access to
some of the country's best scientists
and massive amounts of funding from the
US government newly installed as dean of
the School of Engineering Kerman set
about turning Stanford into one of the
best places in the entire world to be an
engineer in 1945 he was influential in
the creation of Stanford's First
Independent research lab which looked
into further applications for microwave
technology he used his military
connections to help found a new
electronics research lab turman's
mission was helped massively by the
emergence of the next major global
conflict the United States and Soviet
Union never met each other on a physical
Battlefield they didn't fight each other
with guns instead they fought with radar
spy planes and icbms deterrence and
Intrigue mattered more than raw military
force this meant that someone of
turman's reputation could always receive
the funding he needed to do the research
he wanted in areas like electronics and
signals intelligence the military
approached Turman and asked him to
establish an applied Electronics lab
which would perform classified military
work they doubled the size of Stanford's
Electronics program and they in effect
made Stanford a full partner with the
U.S military and government this was big
science at its best Fred Turman
transformed Stanford into the advanced r
d arm for America's military-industrial
complex but going from massive contracts
with the U.S military to the
entrepreneurial culture of Silicon
Valley required breaking some
long-established rules
by the early 1950s Turman realized that
the research he was overseeing in
Stanford's engineering department and
its growing number of independent
research Labs could create huge amounts
of private sector value he also knew
that Stanford was in some financial
trouble so he did something that had
never been done before he spearheaded
the creation of the world's first
University Research Park certainly a lot
of it was based on Research with
practical applications led to Cisco to
Sun
Etc jointly administered by both
Stanford and the City of Palo Alto
Stanford Industrial Park generated
income for Stanford and tax revenue for
Palo Alto but more importantly it
brought together the area's most
promising high-tech companies to share
facilities and knowledge with each other
and the broader Stanford Community the
degree to which Silicon Valley has its
roots at Stanford is essentially the
degree to which Fred Turman was able to
conceptualize and then persuade the
trustees that his concept was
meritorious whether he knew it or not he
was tapping into California's
centuries-long history of risky business
ventures California was always the place
where men and women could come to make
their fortunes the Gold Rush of the
mid-1850s brought Legions of people out
west one of them was Leland Stanford
before he established Stanford
University he was a businessman who made
his fortune selling picks and shovels to
gold miners in a way that's what Turman
did with the Stanford Industrial Park he
gave entrepreneurs the equipment the
facilities the talent in other words the
tools to make fortunes of Their Own
in 1953 the park got its first tenant
remember those two brothers I mentioned
earlier the ones who worked with
researchers from Stanford to create a
device which became a crucial part of
microwave-based radio detection during
World War II their names were Russell
and sigurd Varian and not only were they
the first tenants of the Stanford
industrial park in 1956 Varian
Associates became the first Silicon
Valley company to ever go public one of
Varian Associates first employees was a
payroll clerk named Clara jobs and her
son went on to become kind of a big deal
in technology other notable early
tenants included Hewlett-Packard a
company started by two of Fred turman's
engineering students General Electric
one of the world's biggest semiconductor
manufacturers and Lockheed Martin still
one of the world's biggest defense
companies since then companies like
Tesla Facebook and rivien have all been
tenants of the Stanford Research Park
and that isn't all Turman did instead of
encouraging his grad students to get
their phds which had been the way things
were worked for decades if not centuries
Turman encouraged them to leave and
start companies he himself sat on a
number of corporate boards and suggested
that his colleagues do the same this was
heretical but by this stage Turman had
years of experience doing things that
hadn't been done before by the late
1950s and early 1960s the valley was
teeming with companies that were
expanding the Frontiers in fields like
microwaves vacuum tubes and early
semiconductor it was also crawling with
Soviet spies many companies were still
funded by the U.S government to perform
research and make devices that were used
as part of the Cold War Fairchild
semiconductor won its first business
building chips that helped send American
astronauts to the Moon after setting up
shop in Sunnyvale Lockheed Martin got a
contract to build all the missiles for
the U.S Navy it quickly became the
area's biggest employer eventually
Public Funding was eclipsed by private
Capital but without that critical early
help from the U.S military Silicon
Valley would have never become what it
is today
when Wired Magazine turned 25 in 2018
they threw a party and the party had a
surprise speaker Jeff Bezos Bezos said
something during his talk that ruffled
some feathers take a listen we are going
to continue to support the dod and I
think we should sometimes one of the
jobs of a senior leadership team is to
make the right decision even when it's
unpopular and if if big tech companies
are going to turn their back on the U.S
Department of Defense this country is
going to be in trouble he knew this
wouldn't be popular with the people in
the room but Bezos knew what he was
talking about his grandfather a man
named Lawrence Preston guys was a
founding member of the pentagon's
special research project agency DARPA
and his comments have aged very well the
world is entering an era of intense
strategic competition the threats are
diverse China terrorism Rogue AI black
hat hackers in Russia managing them will
require a close partnership between
technology companies in the Pentagon
some big technology companies understand
the stakes Microsoft has worked closely
with the military for decades and Google
worked with the Pentagon on an AI
project to improve the Precision of
drone operations on the battlefield
however most tech workers absolutely
hate the idea of working with the
military that collaboration between
Google and the Pentagon was shut down
after more than 3 000 Google employees
signed an open letter they got their way
but what they didn't understand is that
Silicon Valley was created because the
U.S government needed to access the best
scientists and engineers in order to
defeat an existential threat today that
need is as great as ever the US
government is investing billions of
dollars to meet the threats of today and
tomorrow that support is enabling the
emergence of a new type of defense
company names like anderill palantir and
SpaceX that want to do totally new
things instead of just doing the old
thing better and they all follow in the
footsteps of men like Fred Turman now if
you'd like to know more about the
financial history of Silicon Valley just
watch this video next thanks a lot